talk about this going to point up the
death card shoot porno who need sound on
pornhub what a [ __ ] loser
what an absolute loser oh my god what a
[ __ ] loser God people really spend
their time on pornhub that [ __ ] is like
7-eleven you get in you get out and you
feel a little gross when you're done not
sure what just happened you didn't want
to have to do it
what the [ __ ] needs sound whatever
absolute deadbeat who was the dialogue
on porn you anything like that was
better
it wasn't even for like the moaning it
was for the [ __ ] dialogue no I want
to know how the Xerox machine broke
what's the actual technical issue is
there a paper jam is it the load tray
what's going on is there PC load letter
I need to know if it's a PC load letter
because I've been having similar
problems with my Xerox machine at work
and I was wondering if how I could
finagle that into a blow job what
[ __ ] idiot my god dude
is he from Sacramento oh Jesus
how did you hear about this Oh San
Francisco yeah San Francisco too many
[ __ ] get rights in San
Francisco man yeah yeah business and
we're gonna go homeless people just have
full-on camp outs
they just set up a tent bro get
apartment at least you know I mean like
do something so I need to see how much I
don't care about homeless people it's
impressive
yo but you come back from India you see
real like holy [ __ ] poverty I seen
poverty in America I haven't seen very
much holy [ __ ] poverty after I saw holy
[ __ ] poverty nothing for these homeless
people nothing excuse me sir do you have
a dollar of course a stupid question who
do you think I am you are not mad
dollars dude you know that's the
everyday person but to you I'm a king
you just want one for doing nothing get
the [ __ ] out of here you always
capitalism baby I'm starting to see why
you poor you got no work ethic can't
just ask me for a dollar and get a
dollar I won't get my brother a dollar
like that that is one thing New York man
that's the free market reigns with
homeless people you got to earn this
[ __ ] I seen an entire mariachi band come
on in my train play a full song I than
one dollar 25 cents in Mexican and you
think you get a dollar just for asking
[ __ ] you you'll pick up an instrument
figure it out bro deaf people who need
more porn rights like you oh come on man
step outside I mean he could I mean he
could you know he could read you know I
mean it's not he's not blind and he's
not Helen Keller yeah I can't believe
deaf people want closed captioning
there's orange
maybe that's how much it yeah how rough
it is to be deaf is you don't realize
like you actually can you imagine
growing up thinking porn stars have
something to say that's crazy
that's it that's a rough existence only
a deaf person could possibly think you
know whose opinion I want to hear you
know I want to hear talk more it's porn
actresses I'm sure they got incredible
things to say and I'm missing all of
them I bet this video is a full blown
Palin head why I should vote for [ __ ]
Joe Biden
crazy man that's a sad life actually for
deaf people I think have it's tougher
than I realized I never thought that
that's how deaf they are I mean like I
was like who would want to listen the
porn actor I got to listen to my whole
life this guy walked around his whole
life thinking porn actresses can talk I
mean I know they could talk but like
come on why would they